-Come on, buddy.
You look fantastic.
It is great to see you.
-I know. I can't help it.
-No. Oh, my -- I want to talk.
I have so many questions.
First of all, the first album
in almost 20 years.
-Almost.
-Yeah, almost. Yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Give me a break.
-How does it feel
to perform the album live?
I saw you last night.
Here's a picture of you.
-Oh, last night
was the first time
that we performed new songs
with the exception
of one or two things,
like "Doom and Gloom."
-Yeah.
-But a great feeling.
You know, the band feels
really good about it.
And a band exists...
am I right, gentlemen --
...on what it does.
[ Laughs ]
-Yeah. And --
-Yeah. "A band exists
on what it does."
[ Cheers and applause ]
I love that. "A band exists
on what it does."
These are gems. These are
little Hackney Diamonds
he's gonna drop
all through the interviews.
You played it --
And we were talking --
I got to see you in London.
And we were talking about
these songs, and you go,
"Well, I think these are good,"
and you go,
"I think they're gonna be good
playing them live."
And I go, "Yeah."
And then you play
this little club last night.
Why didn't you play the --
You surprised everybody.
But why the little club?
-Listen. Bands like us...
And, matter of fact,
all bands and groups,
eventually --
they start in little rooms
playing to a very few people.
-Yeah.
-And -- And that's where
you hone down your stuff
and that's where you --
you got to --
If it gets bigger, good luck.
You know? I mean...
-That's great for you.
But it doesn't necessarily
always get --
-Yeah, but, I mean,
the essence of a band
is in a small room
with a lot of people,
if you're lucky.
-Yeah.
-That's where you work --
work your stuff out.
-You came out, you had -- Look.
I mean, this is a photo
from last night.
There's no tricks.
There's no anything.
It's you and a guitar and drums
and a microphone, and that's it.
And you're like,
"Yeah, put me in the ring.
Let me show you how...
I'll show you...
Come on.
I'll show you how to do it.
Let's go! Let's go!"
Loved it! It was so great!
It was so cool.
Did you notice me there
in the audience?
-I saw you in the back there.
-Yeah, I wasn't in the back.
I was...
[ Laughter ]
But they're great songs.
And now we can talk about
who's on the album.
Lady Gaga was off the chain.
She's on the album.
She was fantastic last night.
-She is on the album.
She insisted on being part
of last night.
And bless her heart.
You know, bless her.
-She crushed it, but also --
Can we talk about this?
This "Bite My Head Off,"
which I think is one of
my favorite songs on the album,
has a bass player.
-That is understandable.
-Thank you. Yes.
Paul McCartney plays
with the Rolling Stones
on this album.
A Beatle. A Beatle.
A Beatle and the Rolling Stones
played on one song together
for the first time.
-No.
-What?
What are you -- What?
-John Lennon and Paul.
First off, they gave us
one of our first big hits,
"I Wanna Be Your Man."
They were the ones
that collared us and said,
"Hey, we've got this song here,
you know?"
-That's right.
-And so we -- Our relationship
with John and Paul
and with the Beatles was --
It went -- It goes back
to '62, '63, you know, and...
-What was the relationship?
Did you hate each other?
Did you...?
-No. We'd play up to that.
I think, you know,
there was, like,
a "Beatles versus Stones" thing
and that.
Oh yeah, yeah, but not really.
-No.
-Meanwhile we're
working together saying,
"Is your single ready?"
-Yeah, yeah.
-And...
-"I'll put ours out."
-"We have a couple
of weeks to go."
"Okay. You go first."
So we tried not to clash
with our stuff.
They gave us songs.
Also, Paul and John are on
a track called "We Love You"...
-Oh, yeah!
-...in the middle '60s.
And another track, "Dandelion,"
that John and Paul
came by to sing, you know.
Because they liked
the Stones too, you know.
-Yeah. So...
That was awesome. Yeah.
You inspired each other.
-Yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-And we don't
have to get too into it
if it makes you sad at all,
but I know your brother
Charlie Watts passed away.
And it was very sad.
We all loved Charlie Watts.
-It is, of course.
-But he got to play drums
on two of these tracks.
And the rest were played --
Steve Jordan, who's phenomenal.
-Steve, who was recommended
by Mr. Watts.
-Yes.
-Which is, you know --
That's the best recommendation
you can get, you know?
-Yeah. Exactly.
-And also
they were great friends.
And it was --
Charlie had always said to me,
"If you're gonna do anything
outside of the Stones,
do it with Steve Jordan."
And now it's turned out
that, you know,
Steve's sitting
in Charlie's chair.
With great reverence.
And we do miss the man so much.
But, I mean,
if there was another guy
that was gonna fill
that seat, it's Steve, right?
Am I right?
-Yeah, yeah. And Steve --
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Uh...
I'm gonna ask you
some questions
that everyone's probably
asked you a million times.
You already told the answer.
But the name "Rolling Stones"
is from Muddy Waters?
-Rolling Stones. Yeah.
We come -- Our name
comes from Muddy Waters.
You know, we come from
a long line of blues players.
And the only reason we are
called the Rolling Stones
is that we were
making a phone call.
We had a gig. This was way,
way back, you know?
-Yeah.
-And we finally got a gig
and we said,
"Let's put an ad out," you know?
And I think it was Brian Jones
at the time.
Called "Jazz News" or something.
"We're doing a gig
at the, you know, Windmill Pub,"
blah, blah, blah.
And they said,
"That's all very well,
but what are you called?"
[ Laughs ] You know?
And down there on the floor
was Muddy Waters' album.
And the first track
was "Rollin' Stone Blues."
[ Cheers and applause ]
There it is.
[ Laughing ]
-You've been a great friend
to our show
and a great friend to me.
Thank you very much.
I don't know if you remember
the first time
you came on this program.
You were -- You were smoking.
-Oh.
-Yeah. In the --
In the dressing room.
Yeah, and we --
And the fire alarms went off.
[ Laughter ]
This is a true story.
And these blinking lights
are all in the hallway,
and I've never -- I didn't know
that this was possible,
but two fire marshals
came down.
-True.
-I know that they exist,
but I'd never seen them.
And it's alarms going off.
"Woop woop woop woop woop!"
And they go into
your dressing room
and you're sitting there
and you're smoking.
You had a --
You had an ashtray
that apparently
would suck the smoke out.
Didn't work, by the way.
And --
-I didn't know it was a sin.
-Yeah.
-The guy came in, and he goes,
"Mr. Richards, you can't smoke."
And you go, "Yeah, I know.
It's not good for your health."
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
Swear to God.
-Yeah.
-I swear. I watched it happen.
But we got talking.
We got talking about something.
And I said --
I saw you do an interview
where you're walking
around your house,
and you have a lemon tree.
-Oh, that. Yeah.
-Yeah, and I go --
-It's vanished by now.
-Yes, of course, but I go,
"Talk to me about your lemons."
You know, I'm fascinated
that you have a lemon tree
and you pick a lemon
and you put it in a drink
and you make lemonade
and you do this, all this stuff.
And you -- We were laughing,
and then we went to a party,
a mutual friend.
And you come in. I go,
"Keith, what's up? It's Jimmy.
How are you doing, man?"
I don't even know
if you remember me.
And you go, "Hey, Jimmy.
How you doing, buddy?
I know it's your birthday."
And you pulled out
of your pocket a lemon.
-I did.
-And you gave me a lemon.
And you said --
You wrote "Happy Birthday."
-I forgot the show-business
aspect of this.
-No. Yeah. Yeah. There's a
show-business story to it.
And you gave me this lemon,
and I loved it so much.
And I just want to tell you,
I took the lemon
and I opened it up
and I took the seed
out of the lemon,
and I put it in a Ziploc bag
with a paper towel.
I'm serious about this.
And I grew a lemon tree
from your lemon.
[ Applause ]
-This is a new one on me.
-No, this is for real.
-Ohh!
-That's -- That's your tree.
[ Laughter ]
That's your tree, bud.
It's 10 years old.
Happy birthday, lemon tree!
It's mine. I'm keeping it.
-You're keeping it.
-More with Keith Richards
when we come back, everybody,
This is -- This is your lemon.